Rise and shine, New Horizons, you’re almost
at Pluto!
Hey guys, Amy here for DNews.
Whether or not you think Pluto is a planet,
it’s a fascinating little body, and after
eight years, the first ever dedicated mission
to the dwarf planet, New Horizons, is waking
up from hibernation to start it’s main mission.
It’s sort of a landmark moment.
Since it launched on January 19, 2006, New
Horizons has spent 1,873 days in hibernation.
That’s about two thirds of its flight lifetime!
Hibernation mode is vital on a mission like
this because Pluto is really far away.
1 AU is the distance from the Sun to the Earth,
And Pluto never comes closer than 29.7 AU
to the Sun.
At it’s furthest, it’s 49.3 AU!
Keeping the spacecraft in an unpowered, hibernating
state while it crosses these insanely large
distances is crucial for conserving power
and reducing wear and tear on spacecraft systems
to keep it healthy.
But it isn’t exactly just powered off.
Onboard flight computers have been monitoring
the systems’ health and sending a weekly
beacon-status tone back to Earth.
And of course, it’s woken up for some exciting
moments like encounters with Jupiter and Saturn.
But this is the big one.
We’re at Pluto’s doorstep and about to
get into some really exciting science.
New Horizons is set to wake up at 3 p.m. Eastern
Time on December 6.
At the time it will be 2.9 billion miles from
Earth, but just a relatively short hop from
Pluto; it will be 162 million miles from the
dwarf planet.
Once it wakes, it will send an electronic
word back to Earth confirming it’s in active
mode, then the team will run systems checks
and get data back that’s been stored on
the spacecraft.
Then before you know it we’ll be at Pluto.
This is actually going to a really exciting
mission.
Not only is this the first ever dedicated
mission to Pluto, this is the first spacecraft
to go beyond Saturn since the Voyager spacecraft
reached the outer solar system in the 1980s.
And needless to say, the instruments on New
Horizons are far more modern and updated than
those aboard the Voyagers that were built
and launched in the 1970s.
But more than just great data, we’re going
to learn some really neat things.
Pluto and its largest moon Charon are a binary
system the same way the Earth and the Moon
are, the only other such pair in the solar
system.
Pluto’s scant atmosphere is also escaping
from the little planet extremely quickly,
much in the same way scientists think the
atmosphere poured off the early Earth.
It’s quite possible that New Horizons’
close encounter with Pluto in July of 2015
will teach us as much about our now planet
as it will about the dwarf planet.
It’s definitely a mission to watch.
Are you guys excited for New Horizons’ encounter
with Pluto next summer?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
catch me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.